This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 2012, a design group in New York City called Pilot Projects rolled out a strip of red carpet in Union Square, a public park in the middle of Manhattan. They hired a floutist and a waiter in a tuxedo who wore white gloves and had a small towel draped over his forearm. And one by one, they served people drinks. Drinks of water from the public drinking fountain. That's our own Katie Mingle. This design group, Pilot Projects, held this event to promote their plan to install
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。2012年，纽约市一个名为“试点项目”（Pilot Projects）的设计团队在曼哈顿市中心的公共公园——联合广场铺设了一条红地毯。他们雇了一位长笛手和一位穿着燕尾服、戴着白手套、前臂搭着小毛巾的服务员。他们一个接一个地为人们提供饮料。饮料就是来自公共饮水喷泉的自来水。那是我们的同事凯蒂·明格尔。这个设计团队“试点项目”举办这次活动，是为了推广他们的计划，即安装
a hundred new drinking fountains in New York City, but not just run-of-the-mill drinking fountains. We're talking about drinking fountains that would be designed by artists and designers and architects. That's Scott Francisco from Pilot Projects. We really want the drinking fountains to be something that people love to use and share with each other.
一百个新的饮水喷泉，但不仅仅是普通的饮水喷泉。我们说的是由艺术家、设计师和建筑师设计的饮水喷泉。那是来自“试点项目”的斯科特·弗朗西斯科。我们真心希望这些饮水喷泉能成为人们乐于使用并与他人分享的东西。
And that there's a sense of pride in the fountains, too. Pilot Projects was hoping to put some prestige back on the drinking fountain. Make it cool again. I know what you're thinking. Drinking fountains have never been cool. No one has ever been like, yo, see you at the drinking fountain later. But you're wrong. There was a time when everyone was like, yo, see you at the drinking fountain later.
而且人们对这些喷泉也有一种自豪感。“试点项目”希望让饮水喷泉重获尊严。让它再次变得酷起来。我知道你在想什么。饮水喷泉从来都不酷。从来没有人会说：“嘿，待会儿在饮水喷泉那儿见。”但你错了。曾经有一段时间，每个人都会说：“嘿，待会儿在饮水喷泉那儿见。”
On the 21st of April 1859, the streets of London were thronged with crowds of people who came to witness the opening of the first free, fresh drinking fountain. That's Philip Davies. He wrote a book about historic drinking fountains in London. And he's talking about the day that the public drinking fountain was the coolest thing in town. The scene was recorded in the London Illustrated News, so we actually have a pretty good idea of what it was like. Women turned out in their best finery. The men had their top hats on.
1859年4月21日，伦敦街头挤满了前来见证第一个免费、新鲜饮水喷泉揭幕的人群。那是菲利普·戴维斯。他写了一本关于伦敦历史饮水喷泉的书。他正在讲述公共饮水喷泉成为城中最酷事物的日子。这一场景被《伦敦新闻画报》记录了下来，所以我们对当时的情况有相当好的了解。女士们穿着她们最好的华服出席。男士们戴着高礼帽。
Children were clambering over the ratings. Everyone was so pumped. There were clambering over the ratings. Everyone was so pumped. There were like water is the best. People I think couldn't believe that they were blessed with something that was so important to them. And if you look at the picture in the London illustrated news, you can see above the fountain engraved in the Stonewall the words, the first drinking fountain. It probably wasn't the first drinking fountain in the history of the world, but it was the first one in London. This fountain was used by thousands of people a day, and to understand its mass appeal,
孩子们在栏杆上爬来爬去。每个人都非常兴奋。他们就像在说水是最好的。我想人们简直不敢相信他们能拥有对自己如此重要的东西。如果你看《伦敦新闻画报》上的图片，你可以看到喷泉上方石墙上刻着“第一个饮水喷泉”的字样。它可能不是世界历史上第一个饮水喷泉，但它是伦敦的第一个。这个喷泉每天有成千上万的人使用，要了解它的巨大吸引力，
you have to understand some things about London before this fountain was installed. Well, a city life in the 19th century, in London in particular, was an absolute nightmare for the poorer classes. And a big part of that nightmare was the drinking water. Most people did not have access to water in their homes. Instead, many got water from the nasty, cesspool known as the River Thames. The Thames was basically a great sewer. It was full of feces and chemicals. It was not uncommon to see dead animals floating down the river. The Thames was so nasty that London has the distinction of having a period in their history called.
你必须了解这个喷泉安装前伦敦的一些情况。嗯，19世纪的城市生活，尤其是伦敦，对贫困阶层来说简直是一场噩梦。而那场噩梦很大一部分是饮用水问题。大多数人家里没有自来水。相反，许多人从被称为“污水池”的泰晤士河取水。泰晤士河基本上就是一个巨大的下水道。里面充满了粪便和化学物质。看到死动物顺流而下并不罕见。泰晤士河太脏了，以至于伦敦历史上有一段时期被称为：
The great stink when the smell from the Thames was so bad that they had to evacuate the House of Commons in Westminster of other river. So some people in London got their water directly from the stinky Thames and other people got it from wells that were also dirty and contaminated with disease. Colora was rampant. Outbreak to the disease in 1847 and 1854 killed 58,000 people in London. And the accepted theory at the time was diseases including cholera were spread through bad smelling air. But some people were skeptical of this, including a scientist named John Snow. John Snow thought the disease might be spread through water.
“大恶臭”，当时泰晤士河散发的臭味太严重了，以至于他们不得不疏散威斯敏斯特的下议院。所以伦敦的一些人直接从臭气熏天的泰晤士河取水，而另一些人则从同样肮脏且受疾病污染的井里取水。霍乱横行。1847年和1854年的疾病爆发在伦敦夺走了58,000人的生命。当时公认的理论是，包括霍乱在内的疾病是通过恶臭的空气传播的。但有些人对此持怀疑态度，其中包括一位名叫约翰·斯诺的科学家。约翰·斯诺认为疾病可能是通过水传播的。
And everyone was all like, you know nothing, John Snow. And he was like, actually, I know that the water is killing you. And I'm going to prove it. He went door to door and said, are you sick or members of your family sick? And he actually marked down on a map everyone who was sick. That's Peter Glick, an expert on water-related issues at the Pacific Institute.
当时每个人都说：“你什么都不知道，约翰·斯诺。”而他却说：“事实上，我知道是水在杀死你们。我将证明这一点。”他挨家挨户地询问：“你生病了吗？或者你的家人病了吗？”他甚至在地图上标记了每一个生病的人。那是彼得·格利克，太平洋研究所的水资源问题专家。
He identified in the center of this outbreak a particular water well. He went, he removed the pump handle so that nobody could pump water from that water well, and the cholera epidemic in this neighborhood ended. No one had ever really mapped disease patterns like this before, which is why John Snow is known as the father of modern epidemiology. John Snow made the discovery that cholera was linked to water in 1854. Shortly after that, a group was formed called the Metropolitan Free Drinking Fountain Association. They later changed their name to the Metropolitan Free Drinking
他在这次疫情的中心确定了一口特定的水井。他去移除了水泵手柄，这样就没人能从那口井里抽水了，结果这个社区的霍乱疫情结束了。在此之前，从来没有人真正这样绘制过疾病模式图，这就是为什么约翰·斯诺被称为现代流行病学之父。约翰·斯诺在1854年发现了霍乱与水之间的联系。此后不久，一个名为“大都会免费饮水喷泉协会”的组织成立了。他们后来改名为“大都会免费饮水
Fountain and Cattle Troph Association, because it was just catchier, you know? And providing clean water for animals also became a central tenet of their mission. They built drinking fountains all over London, including the first one in 1859. Very soon afterwards within five or six years over 80 fountains, similar fountains were erected across London. By 1879 the Metropolitan Free Drinking Fountain and Cattle Troph Association had built almost 800 drinking fountains in London. The association was made up of wealthy,
喷泉与牲畜水槽协会”，因为这样更顺口，你懂的。为动物提供清洁的水也成为了他们使命的核心原则。他们在伦敦各地建造了饮水喷泉，包括1859年的第一个。很快，在五六年内，伦敦各地竖立起了80多个类似的喷泉。到1879年，“大都会免费饮水喷泉与牲畜水槽协会”已经在伦敦建造了近800个饮水喷泉。该协会由富有的、
mostly Christian philanthropists, and they had a couple different agendas in building these fountains. One was clean, safe drinking water for poor people, and the other was temperance. The temperance movement, a social movement that opposed the consumption of alcohol, was an early supporter of this new beverage called water. See, there was a terrible epidemic of alcoholism in London at the time, but not just in London, in a lot of other places too, including the United States, where the temperance movement was also taking hold. And really, the reason that temperance is invented is because alcohol is what people drink.
主要是基督教慈善家组成，他们在建造这些喷泉时有几个不同的议程。一个是为穷人提供清洁、安全的饮用水，另一个是禁酒。禁酒运动，即反对饮酒的社会运动，是这种名为“水”的新饮料的早期支持者。你看，当时伦敦有一种可怕的酗酒流行病，不仅在伦敦，在其他许多地方也是如此，包括美国，禁酒运动也在那里扎根。实际上，禁酒运动之所以被发明出来，是因为酒精是当时人们喝的东西。
That's historian and architect, Marta Gutman. Water is dirty, water is not understood to be a suitable beverage, milk is unheard of, except for babies and coffee into your expensive. So that's it. Men, women, and even children were drinking alcohol all day long. Alcoholism was destroying families. In order to push the temperance movement, in order to fight against alcohol, part of the argument was there had to be an alternative, and one of the alternatives that at this time, once we figured out how to provide safe water, was water. Temperance fountains were built in public parks at churches, and often right outside the
那是历史学家兼建筑师玛塔·古特曼。水很脏，水不被认为是一种合适的饮料，牛奶除了婴儿喝之外闻所未闻，咖啡又太贵了。所以就是这样。男人、女人，甚至孩子整天都在喝酒。酗酒正在摧毁家庭。为了推动禁酒运动，为了对抗酒精，论点的一部分是必须有一种替代品，而当时一旦我们弄清楚如何提供安全的水，替代品之一就是水。禁酒喷泉建在公共公园、教堂，通常就在
local bar, hoping to snag those few people that weren't going in because they wanted to get drunk, but just because they were thirsty. The architectural style of these fountains varied greatly depending on who commissioned them, but they weren't like the drinking fountains you grew up with. They were generally made of stone or granite. That first fountain in London was fairly simple, but they became quite rapidly much more elaborate and were seen, I suppose, as symbols of philanthropy. Some were ornate Victorian Gothic structures, my name, that's really. Quite a common architectural detail here was just a lion's-headed spout from the water came out of the mouth of the lion's head. The ones built by Christian organizations often included a biblical inscription, like
当地酒吧外面，希望能吸引那些不是因为想喝醉，而仅仅是因为口渴而不进去的人。这些喷泉的建筑风格根据委托人的不同而有很大差异，但它们不像你从小见到的那种饮水喷泉。它们通常由石头或花岗岩制成。伦敦的第一个喷泉相当简单，但它们很快变得更加精致，我想，它们被视为慈善的象征。有些是华丽的维多利亚哥特式建筑，我的名字，那真是。这里一个非常常见的建筑细节就是一个狮子头喷嘴，水从狮子头的嘴里流出来。基督教组织建造的喷泉通常包含圣经铭文，例如
the fear of the Lord is a fountain of life. You can still find Temperance Fountains all over Europe and in the US. There's one in New York City's Tompkins Square Park. In Oregon, a lumber tycoon slash Tito learned Simon Benson built Fountains all over Portland. They came to be known as Benson Bubblers, and Portlanders loved them, referred to drinking from them as having a Benson Heimall.
“敬畏耶和华是生命的泉源”。你仍然可以在欧洲和美国各地找到禁酒喷泉。纽约市的汤普金斯广场公园就有一个。在俄勒冈州，木材大亨兼禁酒主义者西蒙·本森在波特兰各地建造了喷泉。它们被称为“本森起泡器”，波特兰人很喜欢它们，把从那里喝水称为“喝本森水”。
There's a fountain in Petaluma, California with the inscription, total abstinence is the way to handle the alcohol problem. Ultimately, drinking fountains didn't handle our problems with alcohol, but they quickly became part of the public landscape. What comes out of it is an idea that there should be drinking fountains in cities. That fountains should not be ornamental, that there should be water available in public for people to drink. As building codes were developed, people started to require a certain number of water fountains in, for example, stadiums, sports stadiums, or in music halls. I think that became an important part of our municipal design.
加利福尼亚州佩塔卢马有一个喷泉，上面刻着：“彻底禁酒是解决酒精问题的途径。”最终，饮水喷泉并没有解决我们的酒精问题，但它们很快成为了公共景观的一部分。由此产生的一个理念是，城市里应该有饮水喷泉。喷泉不应该只是装饰性的，公共场所应该有水供人们饮用。随着建筑规范的发展，人们开始要求在体育场、音乐厅等场所安装一定数量的饮水喷泉。我认为这成为了我们市政设计的重要组成部分。
But it took a while to refine certain aspects of the design. For years, drinking fountains were sort of like a public faucet. You'd set your cup under a spigot and turn on the water. In this cup, it was a common cup that hung from a chain and was meant to be used by all. And then the little sign that says, please, please replace the cup. It was actually a pretty big battle to get rid of the common cup. Public health officials knew it was spreading disease, but people weren't in the habit of carrying their own cup around.
但完善设计的某些方面花了一些时间。多年来，饮水喷泉就像一个公共水龙头。你会把杯子放在龙头下，然后打开水。这个杯子是挂在链子上的公共杯子，供所有人使用。然后还有个小牌子写着：“请，请放回杯子。”摆脱公共杯子实际上是一场相当大的战斗。公共卫生官员知道它在传播疾病，但人们并没有随身携带杯子的习惯。
In 1912, the very first federal regulation on our drinking water was passed to abolish the common cup at drinking fountains. Meanwhile, a drinking fountain was designed that did not require a cup. It was similar to the drinking fountains we use now, the difference being that the water came out in a vertical jet that shot straight up. Which is exactly like the day, but for your mouth. And all of your backwash would just drip straight down onto the spout.
1912年，美国通过了第一项关于饮用水的联邦法规，旨在废除饮水喷泉上的公共杯子。与此同时，一种不需要杯子的饮水喷泉被设计出来。它类似于我们现在使用的饮水喷泉，区别在于水以垂直喷射的方式向上喷出。这和今天的一模一样，但它是对着你的嘴。你所有的回流物都会直接滴回喷嘴上。
Or people would just put their lips onto the spout. This vertical jet style drinking fountain was called, ironically, a sanitary drinking fountain. And in 1920, the American Waterworks Association issued a sternly-worded report that begins. The war against the common drinking cup has been won. This victory, however, must not be allowed to blind us to the dangers lurking in the sanitary drinking fountain.
或者人们会直接把嘴贴在喷嘴上。这种垂直喷射式的饮水喷泉被讽刺地称为“卫生饮水喷泉”。1920年，美国水务协会发布了一份措辞严厉的报告，开头写道：“反对公共饮水杯的战争已经胜利。然而，这场胜利绝不能让我们对潜伏在卫生饮水喷泉中的危险视而不见。”
The report goes on to detail a study of one of these so-called sanitary drinking fountains. Of the 47 people who used the fountain in almost every instance, the lips were placed completely around the metal ball from which the water spurred, and one small boy acted as though he were trying to swallow the whole machinery. It goes on. Of the 47 people, three looked as though they were unmistakably victims of tuberculosis and three had eruptions on their faces. They advised putting cages around the spouts so that we couldn't wrap our mouths around
报告接着详细介绍了一项关于这些所谓的“卫生饮水喷泉”的研究。在47名使用该喷泉的人中，几乎在每一个例子中，嘴唇都完全包裹住了喷水的金属球，一个小男孩甚至表现得好像想把整个机器吞下去一样。报告继续写道：在47人中，有3人看起来无疑是肺结核患者，3人脸上长有皮疹。他们建议在喷嘴周围安装防护罩，这样我们就不能把嘴包在
them. And finally, they advise switching to a slanted or arked jet of water. This, along with the guard around the spout, proved to be the design that stuck. Finally, a drinking fountain we could all get behind, sort of. of. For a lot of Americans, the public drinking fountain conjures an image that has nothing to do with the slanted jet, or the common cup, or with temperance. It's an image of segregation. The segregated drinking fountain during the Jim Crow era in the South
上面了。最后，他们建议改用倾斜或弧形的喷水方式。这加上喷嘴周围的防护罩，被证明是最终保留下来的设计。终于，一个我们都能接受的饮水喷泉了，算是吧。对于许多美国人来说，公共饮水喷泉唤起了一种与倾斜喷射、公共杯子或禁酒无关的形象。那是一种种族隔离的形象。吉姆·克劳法时代的南方，种族隔离的饮水喷泉
means one of the images that haunts us, right? Sharing water made racist America uncomfortable, whether it was drinking fountains or swimming bowls, there's this huge anxiety about the contact of black and white bodies. The Civil Rights Act of 1964 ended segregated public facilities, including drinking fountains, although a handful hung on in the South for a few more years. Even with that darkest period of the drinking fountains history over, it's never really been as beloved as it was when they opened that first one in London in 1859.
意味着困扰我们的形象之一，对吧？分享水让种族主义的美国感到不舒服，无论是饮水喷泉还是游泳池，对于黑人和白人身体的接触都存在巨大的焦虑。1964年的《民权法案》结束了种族隔离的公共设施，包括饮水喷泉，尽管在南方还有少数保留了几年。即使饮水喷泉历史上最黑暗的时期已经过去，它也从未像1859年在伦敦开设第一个喷泉时那样受到人们的喜爱。
Recently public drinking felons have met their most formidable opponent. So in the United States, we consume 9 or 10 billion gallons a year of expensive bottled water, and it's growing 5 to 10 percent a year. That's Peter Glick again of the Pacific Institute. He also wrote a book called Bottled and Sold. The story behind our obsession with bottled water. The consequence of that is billions and billions of plastic bottles that have to be thrown away or recycled. Another consequence, drinking fountains, are starting to disappear from the public landscape.
最近，公共饮水喷泉遇到了最强大的对手。在美国，我们每年消耗90到100亿加仑昂贵的瓶装水，而且每年以5%到10%的速度增长。那是太平洋研究所的彼得·格利克。他还写了一本名为《瓶装与销售：我们对瓶装水痴迷背后的故事》的书。其后果是数十亿个塑料瓶必须被丢弃或回收。另一个后果是，饮水喷泉开始从公共景观中消失。
Despite the fact that many people believe public war is sort of a standard part of any urban design, we have seen movement away from water fountains. The University of Central Florida in 2007 opened a brand new football stadium. They had built the stadium with no public water fountains. And on opening day 45,000 people showed up to watch the UCF nights play the Texas Longhorns. It was an incredibly hot day. Almost 100 degrees, so everyone was thirsty. Bottle water was for sale, of course, but it cost $3.
尽管许多人认为公共用水是任何城市设计的标准部分，但我们已经看到了远离饮水喷泉的趋势。2007年，中佛罗里达大学开设了一个全新的足球场。他们建造这个体育场时没有安装公共饮水喷泉。在开幕当天，45,000人来到现场观看中佛罗里达大学骑士队对阵德克萨斯长角牛队。那天天气非常热。接近100华氏度（约38摄氏度），所以每个人都很渴。当然有瓶装水出售，但要3美元。
And then the bottle water sold out. 18 people were taken to hospitals, and 60 more were treated by local campus personnel for heat-related illnesses. At first, the university was unapologetic, and then some angry students organized into a group called Nights for Free Water. They demanded drinking fountains being installed in the stadium.
然后瓶装水卖光了。18人被送往医院，另有60人因高温相关疾病接受了当地校园人员的治疗。起初，大学方面毫无歉意，随后一些愤怒的学生组织成了一个名为“免费水骑士”的团体。他们要求在体育场内安装饮水喷泉。
We're not out for blood, we just want water, they said. The local press came up with a name for this candle. You'll never guess. Yes, it was Watergate. And finally, the university was forced to concede. They installed 50 drinking fountains in their stadium. The Knights for Free Water probably didn't know anything about their four mothers and
“我们不是要血债血偿，我们只是想要水，”他们说。当地媒体为这起丑闻起了一个名字。你永远猜不到。是的，它叫“水门事件”。最终，大学被迫让步。他们在体育场内安装了50个饮水喷泉。“免费水骑士”可能对他们的前辈——
fathers and the Metropolitan Free Drinking Fountain and Cattle Troph Association. But it's because of them and their tea-todalling brethren in the United States that we've come to expect access to clean, free water in public places. If watergate proved anything, you know, besides Nixon was a liar at Cheat, it's that drinking fountain still matter. And when they're gone, we notice. Because even though we as a society
“大都会免费饮水喷泉与牲畜水槽协会”一无所知。但正是因为他们以及他们在美国的禁酒主义同胞，我们才开始期望在公共场所获得清洁、免费的水。如果说“水门事件”证明了什么（除了尼克松是个骗子和作弊者之外），那就是饮水喷泉仍然很重要。当它们消失时，我们就会注意到。因为即使作为一个社会，
have mostly rejected the idea of temperance and embraced the idea that we love booze forever, sometimes water is still the best. Special thanks to Marta Gutman, a talk she gave on her book City for Children, Women Architecture, and the charitable landscapes of Oakland inspired this story. Bonus Fact. The Metropolitan Free Drinking Fountain and Cattle Troph Association still exists, but they change their name again.
我们大多拒绝了禁酒的想法，并拥抱了我们永远热爱酒精的想法，但有时水仍然是最好的。特别感谢玛塔·古特曼，她关于她的书《儿童城市：女性建筑与奥克兰的慈善景观》的演讲启发了这个故事。额外事实：“大都会免费饮水喷泉与牲畜水槽协会”仍然存在，但他们再次更改了名称。
Now they're just the Drinking Fountain Association. They still maintain London's historic fountains and build new ones in developing countries. The design group we mentioned at the beginning of the piece, Pilot Projects is trying to build 100 new drinking fountains in New York. They're still trying to make it happen, but they need the city to partner with them. If you really enter this, write a note to the mayor's office and ask for better drinking fountains and mention the 100 Fountains project as part of the solution. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Katie Mingle with Sam Greenspan, Avery Trouffman, Kurt Colstead, and me Roman Mars.
现在他们只是“饮水喷泉协会”。他们仍然维护着伦敦的历史喷泉，并在发展中国家建造新的喷泉。我们在节目开头提到的设计团队“试点项目”正试图在纽约建造100个新的饮水喷泉。他们仍在努力实现这一目标，但他们需要城市与他们合作。如果你真的对此感兴趣，给市长办公室写封信，要求更好的饮水喷泉，并提到“100个喷泉项目”作为解决方案的一部分。《99% Invisible》本周由凯蒂·明格尔制作，山姆·格林斯潘、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼、库尔特·科尔斯特德和我罗曼·马尔斯参与。
We are a project of 91.7 KALW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of ArcSign, an architecture and interiors firm, in beautiful, downtown Oakland, California. While Katie was working on this piece, we collectively couldn't get the two-nured song Water Fountain out of our heads, and it just so happens that Rishi at Song Exploder did an episode about that song, which was one of our absolute favorite episodes. So we thought we'd add it here as a little bonus. Enjoy. I want my music to be a product of the world that I am growing up in and growing older in.
我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心，由建筑和室内设计公司ArcSign的办公室制作。当凯蒂制作这期节目时，我们集体无法将Tune-Yards的歌曲《Water Fountain》从脑海中挥去，恰好Rishi在《Song Exploder》中做了一期关于那首歌的节目，这是我们最喜欢的节目之一。所以我们想把它作为一点小福利加在这里。享受吧。我希望我的音乐是我成长和变老的世界的产物。
So if this song is gonna exist as a tuneyard song, it has to have some dirty nasty to it. No, I didn't know what a function. My name is Merrill Garbis and I make music under the name Tuneyards. Nate Brenner is a co-writer on most of the songs now that Tuneyards creates. It was January of 2013 and I was like, okay, it's the new year and I'm going to start to make a new album.
所以如果这首歌要作为一首Tune-Yards的歌存在，它必须带有一些肮脏和粗糙的东西。不，我不知道什么是功能。我的名字是梅里尔·加比斯，我以Tune-Yards的名义创作音乐。内特·布伦纳是Tune-Yards创作的大多数歌曲的共同创作者。那是2013年1月，我当时想，好吧，这是新的一年，我要开始制作一张新专辑了。
And so I kind of forced myself into this routine where I'd go into my little studio, which was a shipping container that had been made into a little rehearsal studio. So I was there in this super hot metal box sitting at a computer and trying to make all these demos. So I had been taking a lot of walks around Oakland, and I was walking around Lake Merit, which is just down the street from where we live. And I would just walk around that lake a whole lot
所以我强迫自己进入这种常规，我会去我的小工作室，那是一个被改造成小型排练室的集装箱。所以我当时就在那个超级热的金属盒子里，坐在电脑前，试图制作所有这些演示。我一直在奥克兰四处走动，我在梅里特湖周围散步，那离我们住的地方只有几条街。我会经常绕着那个湖走很多路，
and passing water fountains, some of them working, some of them not working. And at that time, I was hearing stuff about conservative not wanting to pay taxes. And I just kind of let my brain wander, like, what if no one ever paid taxes and what if no one ever decided that it was worth it to put money into our greater good?
经过饮水喷泉，有些能用，有些不能用。当时，我听到一些关于保守派不想纳税的事情。我只是让我的大脑漫游，比如，如果从来没有人纳税，如果从来没有人认为把钱投入到我们的共同利益中是值得的，会怎样？
Seeing that through my imagination that, you know, no roads, no sidewalks, no water funds. I don't know. There was something about the rhythm of my walking and the rhythm of that phrase that, no, I don't know what I found in that just like came out of that. The lyric and the melody and the sing-song-e-ness of it and the topic of it, I think I'll came bundled up into one. When two years began, I was really interested in rhythm being a huge part of that. I just am super obsessed with the interplay between rhythms and this creation of a greater rhythmic whole when you have these multiple rhythmic voices going on at the same time. I'm super obsessed with the interplay between rhythms and this creation of a greater rhythmic hole
通过我的想象看到，你知道，没有道路，没有人行道，没有水基金。我不知道。我走路的节奏和那个短语的节奏之间有些东西，不，我不知道我在那里面发现了什么，就像从里面出来的一样。歌词、旋律、那种儿歌的感觉和主题，我想它们都捆绑在一起了。当Tune-Yards开始时，我真的对节奏成为其中的重要部分很感兴趣。我超级痴迷于节奏之间的相互作用，以及当你同时拥有这些多种节奏声音时，创造一个更大的节奏整体。我超级痴迷于节奏之间的相互作用，以及当你同时拥有这些多种节奏声音时，创造一个更大的节奏整体。
when you have these multiple rhythmic voices going on at the same time. So the three, two, and the other, two, three. And that was me, you know, in the hot box, just layering claps or one over another and just saying, okay, that's a start to something. And then I kind of would just hear what was missing. Like, where can I fill in even more gaps between those two clapping parts? And what I came up was, was this, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that But it. So it's really those three rhythms laid over each other. I love when things are human and not machine-like, obviously, as anyone listening to this
所以三、二，还有另一个，二、三。那就是我，你知道，在热盒子里，只是把掌声一层一层地叠在一起，然后说，好吧，这是一个开始。然后我会听听缺了什么。比如，我可以在那两个拍手部分之间填补更多的空白吗？我想出的是，那个，那个，那个……所以它确实是那三种节奏叠加在一起。我喜欢事物是人性化的而不是机器化的，显然，任何听这个的人
music would know. It is not perfect by any means, but there's a tipping point at which I go, nope, I was a little bit too off the beat there for yous in a song that I really wanted to be a dance song. The story of this song is basically that I almost threw it away because I thought it was dumb. It just sounded like really simple. I mean think about me spending hours trying to work out laying my collapse over one another and then coming up with the
音乐的人都会知道。它绝不是完美的，但有一个临界点，我会说，不，你在我真正想成为舞曲的歌里节奏太偏了。这首歌的故事基本上是我差点把它扔掉，因为我觉得它很蠢。它听起来真的很简单。我的意思是，想想我花了几小时试图弄清楚如何把我的掌声叠在一起，然后想出
words like no wood in the woodstock. What the hell does that mean? And I was like this is so annoying and I'm annoying and everything sucks and Nate had a hot box across from mine and he would walk over every afternoon. It would be like a sanity check and And I'd be like, this sucks. And he'd be like, no, no, it's cool. And he came in and he played the first bass line that comes in. And I thought rhythmically his bass line was awesome, but I thought, no, it sounds too right. Like if you play in that kind of major key, then it's going to sound too right and it needs to sound a little bit more wrong. We kind of fought about it a little bit in our peaceful way and then he came up with if he's playing in minor. And all of a sudden a color of the song completely changes and that was really important to me
像“No wood in the woodstock”这样的词。那到底是什么意思？我当时想这太烦人了，我很烦人，一切都很糟糕，内特在我的对面有一个热盒子，他每天下午都会走过来。这就像一个理智检查，我会说，这太烂了。他会说，不，不，这很酷。他走进来，弹奏了第一条贝斯线。我觉得他的贝斯线在节奏上很棒，但我认为，不，它听起来太“正确”了。就像如果你用那种大调弹奏，它听起来会太正确，它需要听起来稍微“错误”一点。我们以和平的方式争论了一下，然后他想出了如果他用小调弹奏。突然间，这首歌的色彩完全改变了，这对我来说非常重要，
that the things that the song was talking about to me were really heavy. And so it didn't make sense to just keep the whole song in major. It was like, this is disturbing. That's kind of where he was like, well, how about this? And I was like, how about that?
因为这首歌谈论的事情对我来说真的很沉重。所以把整首歌都保持在大调里是没有意义的。这就像，这令人不安。这就是他当时说，嗯，这个怎么样？我说，那个怎么样？
And then we're like, OK, both. I saved up all my pennies, and I gave them to this special guy. When he had enough of them he bought himself a cherry pie he gave me a dollar a blood soaked dollar I cannot get the spot but it's okay, it still works in the store
然后我们说，好的，两个都要。我存下了所有的便士，我把它们给了这个特别的人。当他有足够的钱时，他给自己买了一个樱桃派，他给了我一美元，一张沾满血的美元，我无法洗掉那个污点，但没关系，它在商店里仍然有效。
it's still this pretty simple major melody but then you just make the baseline minor and all of a sudden it's like the stomach-turning part of the song. We're all of a song you know that something's gonna go down. You know now there are a lot of people involved in Tuneer. It's the record label and our manager and they're like, this is it, man, this is the single, this is the catchy one. Can you please just make it less dissonant? And I was like, no! I really can't.
它仍然是这种相当简单的主要旋律，但你只要把贝斯线变成小调，突然间它就像这首歌里让人反胃的部分。我们都突然知道有些事情要发生了。你知道现在有很多参与Tune-Yards的人。那是唱片公司和我们的经理，他们说，就是这个，伙计，这是单曲，这是朗朗上口的那个。你能把它弄得不那么刺耳吗？我说，不！我真的不能。
I mean, Tuneer had started when I was listening to a ton of dance hall reggae. And there's something about the tradition of reggae that for so many reasons, there is this dissonance and this kind of dub sensibility where there are things that feel wrong or don't link up exactly, but there's so much implied in that disagreement between elements.
我的意思是，Tune-Yards开始时我正在听大量的舞厅雷鬼音乐。雷鬼音乐的传统中有些东西，由于许多原因，存在这种不和谐和这种配音感，有些东西感觉不对劲或没有完全连接起来，但在这些元素之间的分歧中隐含了很多东西。
There's some reggae albums where you feel like the singer came in and sang and couldn't hear the track. And then the track that they end up putting underneath the singer is like a totally different song with a different key. So I love that sense of wrong parts put together, but then when it comes back together as a whole, it has this whole different conversation of wrongness. You know, no water in the water fountain is, it's like a horrible concept, even more so now in California, but in 2013 too, we were talking about the drought and it was terrifying to me to allow my imagination to go that far and think of life without water coming out
有些雷鬼专辑让你觉得歌手进来唱的时候听不到伴奏。然后他们最终放在歌手下面的伴奏就像一首完全不同的、调子不同的歌。所以我喜欢那种错误的部件放在一起的感觉，但当它作为一个整体回来时，它有了一种完全不同的错误对话。你知道，“No water in the water fountain”是一个可怕的概念，在加利福尼亚现在更是如此，但在2013年也是，我们当时在谈论干旱，让我的想象力走那么远，想到没有水从你的水龙头里流出来的生活，这对我来说太可怕了。
of your taps. You know, even just talking about these things now, it's like this really uncomfortable tension in my stomach and I think that's the feeling that I love to evoke in songs where I'm not writing pretty songs for people to fall in love to necessarily. I'm writing songs that sound more like the truth of the world to me, and that has to mean that that's literally built into the song, that's literally built into the harmonies, or the friction or that grating sense of the song. And that's kind of why, I don't know, I was listening to that drum machine stem, and
你知道，即使现在谈论这些事情，我的胃里也会有一种非常不舒服的紧张感，我认为这就是我喜欢在歌曲中唤起的那种感觉，我并不一定是在写漂亮的歌让人们坠入爱河。我写的是听起来更像我眼中的世界真相的歌，这意味着这必须字面上融入到歌曲中，字面上融入到和声中，或者摩擦力，或者那种刺耳的感觉。这就是为什么，我不知道，我当时在听那个鼓机音轨，
at first it's got the cute little cowbell sound. And then throughout the song, as you get to the end of the song it's like this crazy distorted mess of a drum machine. I found this awesome water bottle in the thrift store and it's just like these things that kind of fit into the world of the song like spare parts kind of sounds sounds, like a water bottle, just evokes water somehow. Even if you're not saying, oh, it's a water bottle. There's just something about it that's like, yep, that fits in. So this is where the brilliant John Hill comes in,
起初它有可爱的牛铃声。然后整首歌，当你到达结尾时，它就像一个疯狂扭曲的鼓机混乱。我在旧货店发现了一个很棒的水瓶，这些东西就像那种适合歌曲世界的东西，备件一样的声音，像水瓶，以某种方式唤起水。即使你没有说，哦，这是一个水瓶。它就是有某种东西让你觉得，是的，那很合适。这就是天才约翰·希尔出现的地方，
because he introduced the laser sound. Now, we were so nervous working with other producers, and I'm very possessive of the term producer because I feel like you know I am my own producer But we took the song in at the request of some of our label people and played it for John Hill who's worked on a lot of cool stuff Rihanna and MIA and so he had those lasers for us and And I played those lasers on a sample pad with a stick. So we all agreed that that was again another dance hall element
因为他引入了激光声音。现在，我们和其他制作人合作时非常紧张，我对“制作人”这个词非常有占有欲，因为我觉得你知道我是我自己的制作人。但我们应唱片公司人员的要求带了这首歌，并为约翰·希尔播放了它，他曾参与过很多很酷的东西，蕾哈娜和MIA，所以他为我们准备了那些激光。我用棍子在采样垫上演奏了那些激光。所以我们都同意，这又是另一个舞厅元素，
that amps up the song when it's like, and now the lasers come in. You know what it is? Oh my gosh. That's just me and my voice and my tongue making some crazy roll in there. But then sampled and played on a keyboard. So that we did with John Hill as well. We sampled my voice and then I was able to play it on a MIDI triggering keyboard and I could play chords with my own voice doing that crazy gurgly noise.
当它像这样时，它会增强歌曲，现在激光进来了。你知道那是什么吗？天哪。那只是我和我的声音，我的舌头在里面做了一些疯狂的滚动。但随后被采样并在键盘上演奏。所以我们也和约翰·希尔一起做了那个。我们采样了我的声音，然后我能够在一个MIDI触发键盘上演奏它，我可以用我自己的声音演奏和弦，发出那种疯狂的咕噜声。
I am so captivated by music. The ability to speak without words, the sound itself is telling the story and it's kind of like a big puzzle that even I am trying to figure out. It's so fun! Recording is amazing! And now here's Water Fountain by Tune Arts in its entirety. I said all night, yeah, what you doing there? Nothing much to do when you're going nowhere Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, no way How I wanna hide That's it, we're gonna get the water from you Sure Nothing feels like dying Like the drying of my skin and long Why we just sit here
我被音乐深深吸引。无需言语就能说话的能力，声音本身就在讲述故事，这就像一个大拼图，连我都在试图弄清楚。太有趣了！录音太棒了！现在是Tune-Yards的《Water Fountain》完整版。我整晚都在说，是的，你在那儿做什么？当你无处可去时没什么可做的……没路了，我该怎么躲？就是这样，我们要从你那儿得到水。当然，没什么比死亡更让人感觉像皮肤干燥和漫长。为什么我们只是坐在这里
All they watch us with are till we're gone I can't seem to feel it I can't seem to feel it I can't seem to feel only, only, only, the cold still You will ride the whip, you'll ride the crack The reason fighting back You're in too feelin' You're in too feelin' You're in too feelin' You're in too feelin' You're in too feelin' You're in too feelin' You're in too feelin' You're in too feelin' You're in too feelin'
他们看着我们直到我们离开。我似乎感觉不到它，我似乎感觉不到它，我似乎感觉不到，只有，只有，只有，寒冷依然。你会骑上鞭子，你会骑上裂缝，理由是反击。你太有感觉了……
You're in too feelin' You're in too feelin' You're in too feelin' You're in too feelin' You're in too feelin' You're in too feelin' You're in too feelin' You're in too feelin'
你太有感觉了……
You're in too feelin' You're in too feelin' You're in too feelin' You're in too feelin' You're in too feelin' You're in too feelin' You're in too feelin' You're in too feelin' You're in too feelin' You're in too feelin' You're in too feelin' You're in too feelin' No one in the water, captain.
你太有感觉了……喷泉里没人，船长。
No phone in the phone booth. And you said, oh my yeah, what's your name? Jump back, jump back, and shout it out. Woo-hoo, woo-hoo! We're gonna give the water from your house, your house. I saved up all my pennies, and I gave them to the special guy. When he had enough of them He bought himself a cherry pie He gave me a dollar A blood soaked dollar
电话亭里没电话。你说，哦，我的天，你叫什么名字？跳回去，跳回去，大声喊出来。呜呼，呜呼！我们要从你家，你家得到水。我存下了所有的便士，我把它们给了那个特别的人。当他有足够的钱时，他给自己买了一个樱桃派，他给了我一美元，一张沾满血的美元。
I cannot get the spot I'll put it's okay It's the works in the store Gracie man come and dig my well Life without your water is a burning hell Suck me up with your homegrown rice Anything make me shitness Suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck me, suck Stop and run me, run me, run me, run me, run me, run me, run me And a two pound chicken jazz, better with friends
我无法洗掉那个污点，但没关系，它在商店里仍然有效。格雷西，伙计，来挖我的井。没有你的水的生活是燃烧的地狱。用你家种的米吸我。任何让我生病的东西。吸我，吸我……停止并运行我，运行我……还有两磅鸡肉爵士乐，和朋友在一起更好。
A two pound chicken dance better with two, and I know it, finally Who's the listener of the one that's like dead? Sing, give me your head, a birdie going round and round and round I want in your bed, how do you know get ahead? Whoop, dead, your fingers do not hurt Your fingers do not hurt, give me a chest, give me a breath, I got nothing in correct We're just, we're just, we're just listenin' to what I thought Sound like a bubble, hey, I leave it going, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come and see me, come Facebook, all of us are on Twitter, Instagram, and Spotify, but to find out more about this story including cool pictures pictures and links, and listen to all the episodes of 99% invisible.
两磅重的鸡成双成对跳舞跳得更好，我终于知道了，谁是那个听起来像死了一样的人的听众？唱吧，把你的头给我，一只小鸟转啊转啊转，我想进你的床，你怎么知道如何领先？哇，死了，你的手指不疼，你的手指不疼，给我一个胸膛，给我一口气，我什么都没说对，我们只是，我们只是，我们只是在听我以为听到的声音，听起来像个泡泡，嘿，我让它继续，不，不，不……快来看看我，快来看看我……Facebook，我们都在Twitter、Instagram和Spotify上，但要了解更多关于这个故事的信息，包括很酷的图片和链接，并收听《99%无形》的所有剧集。
You must go to 99i.org. Radio tapio. From PRX. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你必须访问99i.org。Radio Tapio。来自PRX。来自PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。